hello grammarians hello Paige hi David I
say hello to you and I say hello to the
grammarians that was an interesting
thing to say yes cuz there's a compound
sentence
I see so there's this distinction made
in grammar between simple and compound
sentences and today Paige you and I are
going to cover those differences let's
do it so a simple sentence is really
just what it says on the tin a simple
sentence consists of one subject and one
predicate and that's it right so in the
sentence I bought my friends some candy
all right we got our one subject I and
then we have our one predicate walk my
friend some candy mm-hmm now all of this
together is what we'd call an
independent clause I don't want to hit
that too hard right now but you know
when you have this set of subject and a
predicate together and it can be a
sentence that's called an independent
clause I'm not even going to write that
down yeah but a compound sentence is
basically two or more simple sentences
joined together mm-hmm so that would be
two subjects plus two predicates or more
to three a bajillion sure that would be
a very long sentence to read but you
could do it it would be a very very
compound sentence yeah so I visited the
beach and I got a really bad sunburn
mm-hmm
when we're looking at this this is
really two sentences together joined by
the comma and this and right so we have
our subject I visited the beach I got a
really bad sunburn and we have our two
predicates I visited the beach got a
really bad sunburn so the subject in
both these cases is i right but it's
sort of separate it's like I am doing
two different actions correct right
what's important is like even if it's
the same subject if it's I both times
well I don't know how to say this but
just like if it weren't like I visited
the beach and got a really bad sunburn
then it would be a simple sentence
that's simple so okay so page so I'm
looking at this and I see I twice what
if I wanted to condense this sentence
further okay what does that give us is
this a simple sentence or a compound
sentence because this looks like what
you would call a compound predicate
right since since there's only one
subject in this sentence there's only I
and it's only said once right you don't
have a visit to the beach and I got a
really bad sunburn
that whole thing visited the beach and
got a really bad sunburn is you're right
it is a compound predicate but I could
but what you're saying is I couldn't
divide this up into two sentences unless
I put in another subject right you can
say I visited the beach but and that can
be a sentence on its own but you can't
say and got a really bad sunburn as as
its own sentence okay so both of these
things are simple so this has this is
even though this is a compound predicate
it's technically one predicate right
it's it's and even if I'd written a page
and I visited the beach and got a really
bad sunburn that would still be a
compound subject but it wouldn't be two
sentences squished together it would be
one kind of long sentence right you can
have a compound subject or a compound
predicate but that doesn't make it a
compound sentence
what makes it a compound sentence is you
have two parts that can stand on their
own as individual sentences and they're
sort of being put together so let me
change what I wrote here I can just say
instead of two subjects and two
predicates because I think that's
confusing in light of this information
let's just say it is two simple
sentences right or two independent
clauses which you know that terminology
are and if you don't never fear will
cover it and you can learn anything
David out
ow